[Music]
there y'all as you can see I am by
myself doing the show today what
actually ended up happening was we were
going to record the show this afternoon
and only shortly before we were gonna
start recording Tom actually ended up
having to drive his mom to the eye
doctor kind of an emergency appointment
or whatever and her I guess her regular
eye doctor was at his other office which
is like an hour and a half away from our
house so he has to like drive her all
the way over there so he's gonna be gone
until sometime this evening if not later
and I thought to myself well you know
the matinee show has to get done today I
know you know I know it's not as fun
like when Tom's not here and stuff like
that but I like to have things up on
time for you guys so we always have some
content on the day that it's supposed to
come out so since it had to get done
today I said well you go ahead and take
your mom to doctor and I will just
review the movies by myself even though
I'm sad so this week we were actually
going to go to the theater twice but
then we only actually ended up going one
time but the one time that we went was
like really amazing the other two one of
them was on Netflix and one of them was
on shudder so again we covered all the
bases the movie other movie we were
gonna see in the theater was like The
Grudge remake but we just didn't get
around to it we might see it next week
we probably will I don't have high
expectations for that but I'd you know I
like horror movies and stuff so the
first movie that we saw in the theater
this week was one that I mentioned last
week on our when I was talking about
like my top 10 movies of the year and I
said that this movie was on like a lot
of people's top 10 list this year and I
hadn't seen it yet and I will say that
now I'm kind of sad because if I had
seen this before I did the top 10 list
then this would have definitely been on
it I'm not even at just top 10 I think
top 5 this is uncut gems now this movie
it was directed by the safty Brothers
and this I think is their fourth movie I
don't think I've seen any of their other
ones a lot of people raved about good
time with Robert Pattinson you know and
I think this is they kind of have
um an ongoing thread running throughout
their movies of like quote-unquote real
New Yorkers all of whom have like a
fatal flaw or a tragic flaw and that is
definitely the case with this movie and
I have to say Adam Sandler I mean okay
now he very well might get an Oscar
nomination maybe even a win and I'm kind
of okay with that I don't know if that
means it's the end times or I don't know
like you know I kid Adam Sandler because
as much as I'm not a fan of like his
comedies you know happy gilmore was kind
of funny it's like some of these earlier
ones were kind of funny I do feel like
his more recent comedy has kind of just
been sort of lazy he's cut just kind of
like cash in a paycheck which you know I
can't really blame the guy cuz I'd
probably do the same thing if I was in
that situation but when he is given a
serious role he usually knocks it out of
the park I mean punch-drunk love was
great um you know he's been in a couple
of like Spanglish was great and I
haven't seen rain over me or the
Meyerowitz store the Mayra with
Meyerowitz stories which i think is on
Netflix a lot of people have said that
those are really good as well
so he can actually act when he wants to
I think most of the time he just chooses
not to because you know why
all that effort when you can just like
be in sort of like a lazy dumb comedy
and still get like millions of dollars
for it but I have to say that this movie
it's easily his best performance and the
character is what makes this performance
of his so good I think is that he varied
this was a very very difficult role to
play
now when the safty brothers were talking
about making this movie I think they've
been like working on the screen places
like 2009 and Adam Sandler was actually
their first choice they asked me to do
it back then and he didn't want to do it
so when it started going into production
they were actually gonna go with Jonah
Hill which might have been okay but I
don't think it would have worked quite
the same but then Adam Sandler decided
that he would come back and do it you
know this was like eight nine years
later so he said he would do it what I
think that he captured so well in this
because you have to think his central
character whose name is
Ratner he is essentially a very
unlikable person he's very he's just
he's always kind of like ripping people
off he has a gambling addiction he's
very arrogant he's very cocky he kind of
thinks like he's an insider like he
likes to show off about like he knows
all these celebrities and stuff you know
so it's he he's hard to like but then
again like the way that Adam Sandler
plays him makes you almost kind of root
for the guy even though he's sort of
terrible and he's like kind of [ __ ]
over everybody um he has like this weird
I don't know it's I'm not sure if charm
is the right word maybe it is but it's
like it's just watching him was just
like really really compelling because I
was like man if it if a different actor
was in this this very well could have
blown up in their face cuz it could just
bend this is wildly unlikable character
you're just like please die or whatever
but it's like you actually kind of come
to care about him even though he's
essentially a terrible person and I
think that's kind of like an amazing
feat that's like a really hard thing for
the actor to pull off so his character
he plays um and I should say like as
usual I the only thing I knew about this
movie was that Adam Sandler was in it
and that everybody was saying that this
was the best thing that he had ever been
in I kind of knew that it was about like
a jewelry kind of thing and that it was
like a hustler crime type I think that's
all I knew I didn't know it was a comedy
I didn't know it's a drama
or nothing and I hadn't seen any of the
other Sasi Brothers movies so I went
into this like not knowing at all what
to expect really and I have to say that
this movie it was just like riveting
like from the very first frame it was
just you know he plays like he's a
jewelry dealer in New York in Manhattan
in the diamond district and he also has
I mean his professional life ISM as his
personal life is a mess like he has his
wife despises him and you know his kids
just think he's an idiot and his wife's
actually gonna divorce him like after
Passover but they're kind of play I
haven't even told their kids yet or
anything like that so there's like all
this tension with his wife he's also
screwing around and is why
with a much younger girl that works for
him named Julia played by Julia Fox and
I believe this is her first movie and
she like knocks it out of the [ __ ]
park she's amazing in this great but to
have to say I'm not sure if it's real or
not but if it is holy crap you know Tom
Tom notice that very much fantastic as
he said so um so yeah so that's all his
personal life is going wrong and his
professional life what he does is that
he will like take things from because he
has like all these celebrity clients and
stuff you know particularly like you
know athletes and whatnot and um he will
take some of their stuff like on
collateral and then he won't tell them
but it'll go pawn that stuff and then he
takes the money that he gets from
pawning this stuff and then he makes a
bet on something hoping to get the money
back to get the stuff out of pawn except
obviously that hasn't been happening and
he's cut so he's been pretty much
floating loans from one place to another
place his brother-in-law Arno he is also
barred $100,000 from and is kind of heat
him he's hired a couple heavies like to
get it back so that's like one conflict
that he's going through in his life and
then like you know there's just all this
other [ __ ] and then kevin garnett who's
actually like a real-life basketball
player because there's basketball like
figures very um very prominently in this
movie because that's usually what he
bets on his basketball games so kevin
garnett is in this playing himself he
comes there and he wants to borrow this
very very rare beautiful black opal that
um that Howard Adam Sandler's character
has has just acquired and so then there
comes this whole thing recant that where
he like takes the guy's ring is like
collateral and then he goes upon it and
then it's like he doesn't get the opal
back and then it's like he wants to
auction off the opal for like all this
money so he can pay off all these
creditors but you know it's like I don't
really want to like spoil the whole
story or anything like that but it's
like that's kind of where it going it's
like it's a crime movie it's not a
comedy I wouldn't call it a comedy but
it is hilariously funny
it's
and I don't know if this is gonna make
any sense or not but it's like it's not
funny in the way that a comedy is funny
if that makes any sense it's kind of
like just the the humor comes a lot from
like the situations that he puts himself
in because you have to think everything
that happens to this dude cuz basically
this movie could be like Adam Sandler's
worst week ever the movie you know
animated that's pretty much because like
everything that could go wrong does go
wrong but it's like throughout the
courses movie it's like every single
thing that happens to him is his own
damn fault because of his stupidity
because he can't just you know even when
he wins a bet and gets like a
substantial amount of money you're like
okay well you could pay off your
brother-in-law and like half those
people not come after you and kick your
ass but he won't do that it's like and
it's in in a way it's like he's
frustrating because you can tell that he
can't help it you know what I mean that
it's like I have to you know bet this
because he wants like the big score and
I feel like there's something tragic in
his character that he just feels like
it's never enough so it's like even when
he gets like a big influx if he gets you
know he wins $100,000 $200,000 like in a
bet
it's like he could just pay off his
creditors and everything would be fine
you know and he does and he has money he
has like a nice house and and he owns a
business and everything but he just
can't do it it's always like he has to
think he's like well yeah but if I put
this on you know if I put this on a game
and I win you know then I'll be a
millionaire then so it's like he can't
stop himself
so I think in some ways that goes a
little bit of weight or making him more
sympathetic because even though
everything that happens to him is just
because of his stupid decisions you can
tell that there is an aspect of lack of
control like he can't really control his
behavior to an extent so it does kind of
make you feel bad for him I will say
that and I've heard that um that others
safty Brothers movies are like this -
this movie is pretty much if you have
anxiety issues this is gonna trigger
them big time because this movie is
pretty much just one stomach churning
eggs
by a producing film prefer netic leap
aced it's very fast-paced there's always
something happening there's most of the
scenes are like either really really
close ups or they're like you know in
the room and there's like all these
different conversations going on at once
and one's yelling and like they're
talking over each other like pretty much
for the whole movie also the score is
like kind of this weird scored it's like
loud and like sometimes it like um you
know drowns out the dialogue a little
bit like you can still tell what's going
on it's very easy to tell what's going
on but it's almost kind of like a Robert
Altman film in the sense of like
realistic like everybody's talking over
each other but like on coke you know
what I mean it's like that so if that is
something that is gonna bother you
because I have hurt like I have heard
some people that have seen it that
really like the movie but it's like
pretty much it's it's just tense like
from start to finish you will be like
really really anxious because you know
people talking and yelling and stuff
like that makes me really anxious as
well so I was very anxious and also
because you get so invested in Adam
Sandler's character even though he's
kind of awful you almost kind of want
him to succeed like you want him to come
out of it or to realize you know hit the
error of his ways you know like that so
you're kind of rooting for him but at
the same time you're like oh come on man
it's like I can't [ __ ] believe you
just did that so it's kind of like this
you know you just feel like all these
horrible conflicting emotions like while
you're watching it so it's just like the
whole time we run the theater and it's
been out for for a couple weeks I guess
um and we went to see it I guess it was
like 4:30 in the afternoon or something
like that like the day after New Year's
and it was almost full and I feel like I
heard a couple people leaving that just
did that just hated it but most of the
people seemed like they were really
really into it I mean a couple of the
scenes in there I just like by like my
hand went to my mouth was like oh [ __ ]
oh my god like you know what I mean like
I was really really I was really about
it I was like into this movie and
surprise I wasn't sure like how Tom was
gonna feel about it cuz like I said I
never know cuz sometimes this isn't an
arty film this not by any stretch of the
imagination I can see how it might annoy
some people mostly just because of the
way the conversation
because of the sound design stuff like
that I can see that but this is not like
I said it's it's not a mainstream movie
I wouldn't call it that it's it looks
very gritty it looks like a 70s movie I
think it was shot on a 35 millimeter it
wasn't shot digitally so it definitely
has that 70s like grimy kind of
aesthetic to it which I really like and
it also kind of thematically is kind of
like a 70s crime type of thing to accept
like with more humor I guess so I was
kind of curious as to what Tom would
think of it and when we were leaving the
theater I mean he basically said I think
he said the court was he's like that was
like a masterpiece on so many different
levels it's just there's just so much
stuff going on between this like you
know the symbolism of this of this rare
black opal and how it kind of relates to
Adam Sandler's character and stuff like
that this is definitely one that I you
know I'm probably gonna buy because I
want to watch it over and over because
I'm sure there's like a lot of stuff I
miss because like I said there was so
much going on like in every frame like
all these characters in the background
and they're having their own
conversations over there and then
there's one conversation over here and
everyone's yelling and so like you can't
really hear you can't take in everything
like in one go but this one see why this
is getting all the accolades this is
really an amazing like really immersive
movie like I just I was just totally
into it I was totally riveted and it
just like made me it just made me really
really anxious like the whole time I was
watching it like I was just like you
know just my shoulders were all like
hunched over like that and I was like at
the edge of my seat and everything but
you know what I mean and like I said I'm
just kind of sad that I didn't see it
before I made my top ten because this
would easily be in my top ten movies of
2019 I think it would probably be in my
top five movies so I'm really glad that
I got to see it you know 8:24 Studios
they [ __ ] knock it out of the park
again cuz I've liked pretty much I think
every a24 movie that I've seen I haven't
seen them all but you know this is this
is where you go for and like I said I've
if Adam Sandler wins the Oscar that's
gonna be the craziest thing ever like I
never thought I would say those words in
the same sentence but it's like I can
see how I could happen you know what I
mean
and I'm totally fine with it because I
thought this is a [ __ ] great movie
and easily one of my favorite ones that
we saw this year
okay the second movie we saw this week
was on Netflix this actually came out I
think it came out originally on DISH
Network back in July of 2019 and then I
had a brief theatrical released in
August released in August but I actually
never got around to seeing it because
all the work pretty much every review I
saw of it um you know lettuce I didn't
like really read them but it's like a
lot of reviews I saw of it were very
very very negative so I just didn't
bother but then I was like well I'm
looking for new stuff and I'm kind of
running out of like new movies that were
on Netflix and shudder and stuff and I
was like oh okay I never got around to
seeing this one so I'll give it a whirl
this is the 2019 remake of Jacob's
Ladder now most of you will be familiar
with in 1990 Jacob's Ladder which is
kind of something of a classic Tim
Robbins was in it start it's like a
Vietnam veteran who comes back home and
like starts experiencing these really
strange hallucinations seeing demons and
stuff like that you're really not sure
what's real and what's not
now this movie it hits a lot of similar
beats
um Michael Ealy is in it who I
recognized he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
movies but I recognize him from the
intruder which we reviewed several
months ago which was cut which was bad
but like in a really really entertaining
but I made it was like over-the-top and
super fun even though it was like really
cheesy so he's in this starring as Jacob
they've you know obviously they've
updated it too you know these are
veterans returning from Afghanistan
instead of Vietnam as you would because
they wanted to like make it more modern
and essentially the same kind of stuff
happens though it's the same kind of
stuff with this drug that's called the
latter and it's like it's not so much
because I think in the original movie
because I man it's like the original
movie I just watched it probably a year
and a half ago I think and um you know
that was kind of a thing where they
thought that maybe they were being
experimented on or something like that
when they were in Vietnam this one is
more like there's a drug that's called
the latter or it's called something like
that and and it's kind of like they're
giving it to veterans
are coming back like to make the pizza
it's supposed to be for PTSD but
apparently it's like causing it to be
worse you know what I mean like this
making them see demons and stuff there's
still like that conspiracy aspect where
he thinks people are after him he keeps
seeing people with like black eyes and
like fucked-up faces with like their
faces going all crazy and [ __ ] like that
just like in the original movie you know
there's one scene was like a you know
prostitute or something or a drug dealer
so it was like with big demon wings and
[ __ ] like that which is kind of like an
homage to you know the scene with the
tail in the in the original movie like
at the party but you know it's like
there's a couple of different things
that are added to it that weren't in the
original like in this one Jacob he
actually has a brother named Isaac and
at the beginning you think because Jacob
is a doctor medic and so you think at
the beginning that when they were in
Afghanistan like his brother got killed
and he was like trying to save him like
without knowing that it was his brother
cuz I guess he's still like a mask on
his face or something like that
then he finds out that his brother and
brother died so it's like then you kind
of then he comes back home and he's
still upset about his brother being the
only been like eight months later or
something like that or a year later and
um but then later on in the movie and
it's like there's spoilers so you know
it's like I said this isn't this has
been out a while and I feel like it
really didn't get that like people
didn't really seem to get that much of a
[ __ ] it's like I don't really feel all
that that's because it's like it's not a
terrible movie by any stretch of the
imagination it's just a pointless movie
because I mean me and Tom are watching
it and I said you know it's like I read
so many like reviews [ __ ] on this
it's not awful it's just I don't see
what the point of it was like they did
make it more contemporary they did add a
few elements that weren't in the
original like I said the you know the
guys brother and then like he thinks he
died in Afghanistan but then he turns up
and really he's alive and the ending is
a little bit different but I mean it's
the same type of thing but it's kind of
like
different and to me it's like I was
paying attention but the time line
seemed a little muddled I mean in the
first one you know in the original you
know you get that it's kind of like you
know a spoiler alert for a movie that
came out in you know twenty thirty years
ago you know that you know it turns out
the Tim Robbins never left Vietnam that
he's this whole movie has been like his
you know he's kind of like dreamlike
journey like as he's dying you know to
kind of like accept his fate and
everything like that so this one kind of
goes a similar direction but not quite
but I didn't really get what the
timeline was it's like when exactly did
he die it's like did he die later it's
like was his brother really alive I
didn't really get it so and like I said
I was paying attention I thought but
maybe it's like maybe I missed something
I'm not really sure so it's like they
did a little bit different with it but I
don't know it's it's hard to say because
it's like I'm not I don't I'm not one of
those people it's like automatically
comes out it's like oh they should never
remake movies ever but a lot of the
times it's either like it seems like you
can't win because if you make one that's
like just like the original why bother
if you make one that's so that's really
different from the original why don't
you just call it something else because
it's no longer the original movie
anymore so it's just like it's this
weird catch-22 and it's like I don't see
why anyone would really want to do it
it's like I understand that you know
Studios want to do it because it's name
recognition - blah blah blah but I mean
Jacob's Ladder seemed like a strange
movie to remake because I mean I think
it you know it was a decent hit at the
time back in 1990 and I think it has
like something of a cult following but
it's not like it was a big deal you know
what I mean it's not like it was this
big like cultural touchstone it's and
most people have seen it but it I don't
think it made quite the cultural impact
that some other movies have made so it
just seemed like a weird thing to remake
and if you're going to remake it you
know the the director or the writer
rather who was a Jeff cooler I think
he's the same guy that wrote Midnight
Meat Train the movie adaptation of the
Parker story you know he was like yeah
we wanted to like update it to
Afghanistan we had to come at it from a
different way because you know
culturally our understanding of you know
war like the Vietnam War and the wars in
Afghanistan that's like two different
kind of two different things like people
perceive them just differently so we had
to do something different with it but
that said it's like I don't know if they
did that much differently I mean pretty
much the only things I mean there was
even there's even scenes in this were
they pretty much like like there's a
scene in it where he's talking to his
psychotherapist and they pretty much
lift that whole that whole scene like a
dialogue from the original with him and
his chiropractor where he was talking
about you know if you see all these
things and like you think they're demons
because you don't want to go but it's
like you know if you accept your fate
it's like they look like angels and
stuff so they pretty much lifted that
whole entire scene they just changed the
setting a little bit and they changed
the character a little bit so I feel
like it it wasn't enough of one thing it
was like too similar to the original but
then the stuff that they did differently
didn't really it wasn't all that
compelling everyone in it like all the
actors were fine Michael Ealy was fine
like the guy that played his brother was
was good and was fine it's just I don't
it just seemed like not worth the effort
you know what I mean it was like I said
it was a perfectly enjoyable movie it's
like if I wasn't bored or anything like
that but it's just it seemed very
throwaway like it seems like one of
those movies where you know you know a
month from now I'm gonna forget that I
even watched it just because it didn't
really make much of an impression it's
not it's not as scary it's the original
I thought the original was actually much
creepier I think because it was slower
it was more ambiguous you know the
really and it's like even now that they
have CGI so obviously they had to CGI
all the demons and CGI all the all the
faces vibrating and all the other stuff
and it just doesn't look as good you
know what I mean it's like the original
one you know those were largely
practical effects and it
me it just looked more real it looked
like it was there it looked a lot
creepier that and the new one just
didn't really have that creepiness or
that you know that eeriness to it that
the original one had so you know it's
like if you don't have anything better
to do and you're curious like to see
what a slightly different take on
Jacob's Ladder would be you know but set
during the Afghanistan wars instead of
Vietnam then you know by all means check
it out like I said it's not awful um you
know it's but it's nothing to write home
about either and I feel like that's kind
of like I get that's probably like the
majority of movies and it's like you
know that's I guess it's better than
them like sucking out loud but you know
they're just not particularly memorable
and like I said I don't really see why
anyone felt the need to remake it when
you know there's other movies out there
I've always been a big advocate of like
if you're gonna remake a movie take one
that sucked the first time that was like
a good concept but was like really
poorly executed and make it good you
know what I mean
don't take like a brilliant movie and
just try to remake it because that's
just not gonna work out take something
that sucked the first time but they're
like oh man that could have been so good
if ABC and D and do that do ABC and D
and remake it and make it a [ __ ]
kick-ass movie you know I mean it's like
I don't know why more people don't do
that but uh well I mean I dunno but I
wish they would like that it's like
don't take something like Jacob's Ladder
which was a pretty beloved like
psychological thriller you know that was
like really creepy and kind of like
low-key and everything and then just
kind of remake it in this sort of like
yeah kind of way where it's like it's
alright but it's like I don't know I
just didn't really see the point of it
but like I said your mileage may vary so
if you want to check it out it's on
Netflix right now
you
and the third movie that we saw this
week this was weird when you guys this
one is called lose now I had been
hearing some buzz about this movie it's
a horror film it's German
mostly and it was kind of like making
the festival rounds in 2018 although it
didn't get a wider release until this
year and shudder just added it a couple
of days ago so I thought oh I've been
wanting to see this because I've been
hearing a lot about it so I decided to
check it out last night now this is
another movie where and I this is
something we discussed when we were
talking about that movie perfect a
couple weeks back how you respond to
this movie is going to depend very much
on what your tolerance is for super arty
pretentiousness and I don't mean that in
a bad way necessarily because I did like
this movie even though I have to admit I
don't I don't think I really know what
the hell happened did it and you will
understand it if you watch it so
basically it's directed by Tillman's
singer and this is their first movie
it's only 75 minutes long although it
feels pretty long just because of just
the way it is this is a very very
experimental film now I will one thing I
will say about it like the whole
aesthetic of it like the style of it is
really really cool they they shot it on
a 16 millimeter it looks exactly like an
old jell-o film from the 70s like it
looks like all garage a and grainy it's
like it doesn't really say what year
it's supposed to be taking place in
although it kind of looks like the early
80s maybe late 70s early 80s because
there's like a lot of neon you know the
way people's hair is the way their
clothes are and stuff like that but it's
cut you know the way the TVs look and
stuff but um it's kind of hard to tell
but this story such as it is and I'm not
sure if this is correct Hertha but
basically what it is is there's a girl
named Luz and she's from Chile
and so she speaks Spanish throughout
most of the movie like most of the other
actors in this pic germinal there's some
of like there's also some English in
there too so it's kind of like you
really need the subtitles going on and
like that it's just I don't know it's
just like a really weird experience so
basically there's a there's a girl named
Luz she's a cab driver and apparently
she met this girl when they were at like
a Catholic school together and she has
this like prayer quote unquote that she
says that's like blasphemous and
apparently her saying this prayer like
summoned a demon I think and the demon
is either she's either passing it from
person to person like a disease or the
demon went into someone else and is
trying to get back to her I'm not super
clear on that but basically there's not
a lot of characters in this it's just
like lose it's like her friend and then
it's like this doctor that the friend
meets in the bar and like she gives him
the demon and then suddenly he's like
hypnotizing Luz and she's saying what
happened to the friend like how she got
the demon so it's just very very strange
like the aesthetic of it is very very
cool like the music and it is really
cool like especially if you like like
early 80's like post-punk like if you
like that sound if you like that like
that that look if you like like 70's
Italian you know kind of euro horror
kind of look you will really like dig
like the way this looks I mean I really
thought it was cool it has it almost has
a little bit of a Cronenberg vibe to I'm
not sure if that's just because of all
the wood panel thing but it's like it
reminded like there were shots in it
that reminded me of like David
Cronenberg's like really uh his early
stuff like shivers it's just I'm not
quite but it's like that kind of weird
chill enos that a lot of his like early
films had like I said with all the wood
paneling and like the weird like long
shots and stuff so it kind of reminded
me of that I will say that the the
oka the movie in the middle part where
this where the psychiatrist is the
psychiatrist or something and then
there's cops and then there's a train
there are a cop and there's a translator
and they are hypnotizing lose to you
know get her to say what happened um you
know the night of there was a car
accident and we'll like when the friend
got the demon or whatever and it's
almost kind of like it's it's like
experimental theater because it's all in
one room like they're in one room and
she's reenacting it because she's
hypnotized so she's reenacting like
driving a car and stuff but she's only
just sitting there but then they put
sound effects in there like a gear
shifts out and like tyre sounds and
stuff so it's like so it's almost kind
of like this weird almost like thought
that I was watching one of those like
really weird experimental theater pieces
you know what I mean where it's like
just one person like sitting in a chair
on a stage but then like they're miming
things so a lot of the movies like that
so it's kind of like so if that sounds
like something that you'd be like oh
[ __ ] this then you will probably hate
this movie and I could see how people
like some people are gonna hate this
movie this is gonna be a really really
polarizing it's very very very
pretentious it's very very very arty you
know and I think that this is one that
I'm gonna have to probably watch again
because I'm not sure I'm not really sure
I got entirely what was happening like I
got that there was a demon and I got
that it was passing from person to
person and I got that loose apparently
summoned the demon because of her
blasphemy but I didn't really get like
why like why was it going from person to
person like what was going on and like I
said that I didn't get the timeline like
I didn't really get you know the there's
like this really weird like the first
literal first shot of the movie is lose
walking into this you know the office of
the psychiatrist I guess you don't
really I didn't know that until the end
but she walks into the lobby and she's
walking kind of like a zombie and then
like she just goes and gets like a soda
out of the machine and just stands there
and drinks it and there's like a guy
working behind the desk and it takes
like a really long time like she just
like
pulls in like really slowly then she's
like putting the stuff the change in the
Machine and then like she's drinking the
sodas and I'm just like what the where
are they going with this so I could see
like how people would be really bored by
that because it does some of the scenes
like Irish myths like really really
really prolonged and it's like kind of
painful to watch because it's you're
just like what is gonna happen with this
but then again it's like some of the
imagery of it is like really really
interesting so is I feel like there's it
feels a little bit like a student film I
have to say like I said it feels a
little bit like an experimental stage
play because there's not a lot of sets
you can tell that they didn't spend a
lot of money on this cuz it's basically
just a handful of characters and just
like a handful of locations so you know
like I said a lot of it takes place like
in this big conference room type of
thing where she's kind of like
hypnotized and like acting stuff out but
you know I think there's like some germs
of some cool [ __ ] in there and I feel
like a lot of critics have been like
really really liking this they I think
some of them kind of said the same thing
that it's like well you know this is
like a director to watch you know if
they had more money and could do
something like a for larger scale but as
I said you know if if you're not into
like arty-farty horror you're gonna hate
this and you will probably turn it off
within five minutes because like I said
the opening scene is just like this
really really long and it feels like
it's not going anywhere but that's it's
like I I don't want to I don't want to
say I enjoyed it but it was also kind of
I don't know is it I I think I need to
see it again like to get a better handle
on it because I feel like I was kind of
paying attention to it but then like Tom
was kind of half watching it and I could
tell that he was probably thinking holy
[ __ ] like another one of these [ __ ]
movies but she's like making me what he
wasn't really watching it he was like on
his tablet or whatever but so I was just
like imagining like what he was thinking
about it so that kind of like that gives
me like a little bit of stress so I
can't really like relax and take in
movie like the same way if I could if I
was watching it by myself I guess so I
would probably watch it again like to
get a whole thing but you know if you're
into real traditional horror this is not
like it's not super gory it doesn't have
like any really big it has like a couple
scenes of like blood and stuff like on
people's faces like one guys to like
kind of sticking a pen up his nose and
it's like as nosebleed and stuff but
[ __ ] it's nothing like gory or nothing
uncomfortable I mean it is a horror
movie in that sense but it's definitely
not a traditional horror movie so if
you're into the more like traditional
horror movies like you know slashers and
stuff like this you will hate this but
if you're kind of more interested in
just that this kind of weird
experimental [ __ ] like from the 70s and
like I said eyes and I saw another
review of this - I think it was sinister
reviews because I really liked that guy
he was saying he didn't really know to
make of this movie which I thought was
very funny but um he was kind of like if
you had showed me this movie and told me
that it was made in 1970 in the 1970s I
would have believed you and I mean they
captured just the look of it's like the
look of the film like the feel of it
just the way it's shot really does seem
like an old euro horror movie from that
time I mean they really [ __ ] nailed
the whole aesthetic of that but you know
like I said this is gonna be definitely
polarizing and I hesitate to recommend
it to anyone unless you are really
really into like super arty weird
[ __ ] movies and this is probably
weirder because we talked about perfect
like I said which is also was also super
pretentious and arty-farty and stuff I I
don't know if I enjoyed that one more
than this one this one's like grittier
grimy ER it's kind of more low-budget II
looking whereas perfect was a lot more
you know slick brightly colored this
one's very muted
you know like some of the scenes like
take place just like in rooms full of
smog or something so you know it's hard
to compare that way but the it's just
one of those movies that you
you're either gonna love you're gonna
hate it so like I said if you swatch it
you hate it I warned you I'm just saying
I'm not sure if I enjoyed it or not but
it was definitely interesting and I
wasn't really bored like I was kind of
intrigued as to where it was gonna go
and what they were gonna do with it and
stuff like that so I didn't like ever
feel like what the [ __ ] is this and like
I was gonna turn it off or anything I
was interested to see what would happen
at the end but you know like I said
everyone's gonna be different and but
it's on shudder if you want to check it
out and you know come to your own
conclusions about it and if you figure
out what it's about then please tell me
because I think I don't really
[Music]